[Musica]
nell'estate del 2020 nel pieno della
campagna mondiale di ricerca di un
vaccino contro il covip alcune
istituzioni impegnate in tale ricerca
sono state vittime di attacchi
informatici che miravano a rubarne e e
manipolarne i dati pochi mesi dopo è
stata la volta della catena del freddo
per la distribuzione dei vaccini che è
stata oggetto di un attacco informatico
la tutela della salute di tutti in
questo sforzo collettivo nel mondo reale
è stata messa a rischio da operazioni
che si sono svolte nel mondo virtuale e
questo è dovuto al fatto che ormai la
nostra vita è intimamente connessa
all'utilizzo di tecnologie di
informazione e comunicazione
quando utilizziamo il nostro telefono il
nostro computer
agiamo nel cosiddetto ciberspazio cioè
quel dominio interattivo fatto di reti
digitali che servono ad archiviare
modificare e comunicare informazioni il
fatto che gli attacchi informatici siano
così frequenti può dare l'idea che il
ciberspazio sia un mondo senza regole
nel quale l'unico limite a quello che si
può fare è dato dalla tecnologia stessa
ma questo non sarebbe corretto
esistono dei limiti giuridici a quello
che si può fare nel ciberspazio e io in
particolare mi occupo dei limiti per
sono stabiliti dal diritto
internazionale
chi sono le vittime di questi attacchi
informatici beh a volte sono gli stati
stessi i loro rivali sulla scena
internazionale cercano di carpirne i
segreti
molto più spesso le vittime siamo noi
persone comuni
quando una vulnerabilità nel nostro
smartphone è sfruttata da un ater per
accedere ai nostri dati personali e il
nostro diritto alla privacy ad essere
violato e rischi molto più alti si
verificano quando a essere oggetto di
attacchi informatici sono infrastrutture
critiche per il vivere civile
pensiamo ad attacchi informatici contro
ospedali o strutture elettorali
che mettono a repentaglio il diritto
alla salute di tutti
ho il diritto al voto e alla democrazia
chi si cela dietro questi attacchi
informatici questo è spesso difficile da
verificare perché il mezzo informatico
dà la possibilità a chi opera in
quell'ambito di nascondere le proprie
tracce
molto spesso a condurre attacchi
informatici sono persone comuni
criminali che agiscono per tornaconto
personale
altre volte sono governi stati che
lanciano direttamente con sponsorizzano
indirettamente attacchi informatici
lanciati da qualcun altro
di fatto il ciberspazio ormai divenuto
un nuovo palcoscenico del teatro delle
relazioni internazionali
dicevo poc'anzi che all'alba dell'era
internet si pensava che il ciberspazio
fosse un mondo nuovo senza regole nel
quale ognuno poteva comportarsi come
meglio credeva oggi questa idea è stata
abbandonata tutti gli stati sono
d'accordo nel dire che il diritto
internazionale esistente si applica alle
operazioni informatiche
lo sforzo che mi ha fatto è quello di
adattare regole che sono state concepite
per un contesto differente o
interpretarle per i nuovi fenomeni
quest'opera di adattamento
interpretazione si svolge spesso presso
organizzazioni internazionali come
l'organizzazione delle nazioni unite e
io stesso ho partecipato ad alcune di
queste discussioni
quando parliamo di diritto
internazionale applicabile nel
ciberspazio pensiamo essenzialmente a
due tipi di regole
da una parte abbiamo divieti di condurre
certe operazioni informatiche dall'altra
abbiamo obblighi di prevenire di ergere
delle difese contro certi attacchi
informatici
occupiamoci delle due in serie iniziamo
dai divieti una strategia d
e cibernetica efficace non può fondarsi
solo sul divieto di condurre certi
attacchi informatici
perché come spiegavo prima è facile
nascondere le proprie tracce quando si
opera nel mondo virtuale
di conseguenza è molto difficile a volte
capire chi abbia violato quei divieti
una strategia di sicurezza cibernetica
internazionale efficace ha bisogno che
ogni stato rispetti i propri obblighi di
prevenzione di certi attacchi
informatici e quindi per tornare ad
alcuni esempi che facevo prima
è importante che ogni stato protegga le
proprie infrastrutture sanitarie ed
elettorali contro attacchi informatici
io ai miei colleghi presso l'università
di oxford ci siamo fatti promotori di
questi obblighi quando uno stato
protegge le proprie infrastrutture
informatiche realtà protegge anche altri
stati
perché c'è sempre un rischio che le
operazioni informatiche si propaghino ad
altri sistemi a volte oltrepassando i
confini nazionali e quindi ogni stato ha
il dovere di fare il proprio meglio per
evitare che attacchi informatici rivolti
contro le proprie infrastrutture possono
diffondersi alle infrastrutture di altri
stati
quando parliamo di misure difensive
protettive cosa abbiamo in mente il
diritto internazionale lascia un margine
di manovra agli stati ma possiamo
certamente fare alcuni esempi ne ho
cinque ha a disposizione
il primo è l'adozione di un quadro
normativo adeguato che disciplini il
comportamento nel mondo virtuale e che
ad esempio definisca il fenomeno della
criminalità informatica
un secondo esempio è la creazione di
strutture nazionali che coordinò la
sicurezza informatica e garantiscono una
risposta coerente e veloce agli
incidenti
un terzo tipo di misure riguarda
specifiche tecniche si possono ad
esempio ad adottare delle procedure di
verifica della sicurezza dei servizi
totti informatici che vengono utilizzati
nelle infrastrutture critiche
una quarta categoria di misure
protettive riguarda gli obblighi di
formazione di personale specializzato ma
anche gli obblighi di educazione della
popolazione di tutti noi ad adottare
pratiche di sicurezza informatica
infine un quinto esempio forse il più
efficace di misura protettiva riguarda
la cooperazione internazionale
il dialogo fra gli stati molto a
condividere informazioni sulle minacce
informatiche ea condividere anche
competenze tecniche per effettuare
operazioni congiunte dicevo all'inizio
che alcune istituzioni di ricerca sul
vaccino contro il copit sono state
oggetto di attacchi informatici
beh quegli attacchi nell'estate del 2020
sono stati identificati per tempo da un
gruppo di stati che hanno agito di
concerto e hanno provato porvi rimedio
un esempio nel quale la cooperazione
internazionale ha funzionato
questo ci dimostra che se ogni stato
prende seriamente il proprio impegno a
comportarsi responsabilmente nel
ciberspazio impegno che deriva dal
diritto internazionale
tutti noi possiamo trarne un beneficio
nel godere delle opportunità che le
nuove tecnologie ci offrono questo tema
va messo al centro dell'agenda pubblica
perché da esso dipende la sicurezza dei
nostri diritti
[Musica]